[Música]
otra noche de angustia para el pueblo de
kiev a las primeras horas del domingo Se
oyeron varias explosiones en la región
durante ataques con drones y misiles
según las autoridades la defensa aérea
destruyó todo lo que se dirigía hacia la
capital ucraniana en un perímetro
cercano en las últimas semanas los
ataques rusos sobre el país se han
intensificado el sábado la ciudad del
libro en el centro del país fue atacada
según el presidente de Ucrania no fue
alcanzada una zona Residencial matando a
una niña hiriendo a 22 personas los
rusos atacaron la ciudad atacaron entre
dos edificios de residenciales de dos
plantas por desgracia hay gente bajo los
escombros también aumentan los ataques
al otro lado de la frontera en la región
rusa de vigorosa el gobernador local
afirmó que los bombardeos ucranianos
mataron a dos personas el sábado
los pueblos en primer lugar al distrito
de ácido bombardeado
a que escuchen la posición de los
autoridades y abandonen temporalmente
sus hogares para salvaguardar lo más
importante su vida y la de sus allegados
por su parte quien dijo que esos ataques
fueron llevados a Cabo por paramilitares
rusos Opuestos a Moscú